cette histoire de réseau ce capital
social qu'il faut absolument se
constituer et ça c'est très important
et là on peut voir aussi bien sûr c'est
le grand orient au niveau de la franc
maçonnerie c'est le club de l'automobile
c'est le siècle on en a beaucoup parlé
il y à quelques temps pour à cause
d'olivier duhamel et du scandale qui est
autour de lui on voit aussi souvent
quand on remarque quand je dis quand
orient club de l'automobile et tout cela
on voit aussi que c'est souvent des
élites ou des lieux de réseaux très
masculin qui sont en train de s'ouvrir
peu à peu aux fans mais c'était aussi
des boys club très très fort en
angleterre c'est encore le cas aussi
très fortement le grand orient vient à
peine de s'ouvrir aux femmes le club de
l'automobile est encore fermée donc il
ya aussi quelque chose comme ça c'est à
dire que c'est au sein de l'élite
il y à une élite si je puis dire il ya
l'élite suprême au sein de l'élite
parce que effectivement peu de femmes
dans ces milieux-là peut évidemment de
jean femmes aux hommes d'origine
étrangère et donc la france aussi est un
petit pays de ce point de vue là qui à
ne pas trop ça discrimination positive
tout ce genre de choses et il la
république eh bien finalement bas
n'intègre pas si bien que cela les
différences si je puis dire
deuxième chose il ya aussi je pense le
peuple entre guillemets attend aussi une
éthique de comportement
une éthique des helix c'est important on
dit souvent vous savez les ministres
devaient être exemplaire et c'est très
bien mais parce que forcément comme je
disais précédemment aussi on les élites
servent de modèles elles sont la can
pour tenir un peu quelque chose tenir
les structures mais elles doivent les
tenir pour l'intérêt général
et là on a l'impression qu'elle ne
tienne les structures plus que pour elle
dans un processus souvent d'auto
légitimation
[Musique]